welcome to this video plug em western
played him before me recently that's
curious the statistics s arm I lost to
him once which must be the game I was
just thinking of but if maybe I played
him earlier with them other accounts
pretty sure or maybe there was some some
guy that has a similar name like you and
dr. Weston or something okay but let's
get back to the game we have a reti
opening his plate with be 3d three and
so on this very solid set up which
nevertheless some contains some some
poison of course I'm myself play the
ratty um regularly too quite often the
Sun is some an interesting way to play
but I just blundered see Sapna he didn't
really take it for whatever reason I
guess there is no reason we came and
let's take care what this was my
original intention anyway
yeah all this is sam this is very dumb
yeah but you cannot have those great
games every every time yeah he wants to
play put the night against bishop but
still it feels like you I shouldn't have
any any big problems or not not no
problem at all we're trying to do is get
the King to just to cover to cover c7
gayatri didn't want to see 95 so you
know yeah if I've we can try e5 maybe
five activating the rook
d for playing b5 s'okay didn't go for
that night to be fine
yeah it's not very comfortable not at
all tending would be some
hmm Kim you don't have much choice no
check yeah I know he can take and play d
5 this is really ugly
you have led to some very lackluster
lackluster lips this work check hmm
always tries to play it Jang Lili check
sophisticated fashion going to a king
and porn end game or not d five noms not
playing d5 yeah well this is a zoosk one
anyway or not I'll get a pledge for each
498 can take g3 actually and maybe do
that
Wow check this game was no fun I'm not
sure if I'm losing really and so I mean
I still ever be gone on down wit sir
it's a protected so it's a bass born
some not to not show at all
hmm yeah maybe maybe can just maybe can
just come around here King to be seven
but what I'm trying to do is to
introduce Bishop c5 me to at least get
this in the position
yeah I know it's very ugly don't have
time to calculate it
yeah it's probably just nonsense you can
play g6 I can just play g6 video tech
check yeah I made it much easier for him
than not that necessary much easier yeah
I know he doesn't he doesn't even need
to calculate can just play play nothing
moves this isn't even precise but it's
enough
yeah cam girl hardcore smart black
resign hit the wrong button yeah this
was a very uninspired game I was safe
the IOC's in very good shape him I just
played this I just played this too too
relaxed I didn't really took it serious
here and this is a mistake yeah maybe I
need to take on on on e4 it's a bit of a
thankless task this position probably I
need to do something like that try to
control the slide yeah something like
this is the lightest the better piece
but it's so this is said this is a
playable position for black I don't
really don't really fear that so much
King here can look to the eighth yeah
he's pleased playing out some moves but
this is just okay for black I have no
problem here whatsoever I need to take
on if Roy yeah I didn't after after
allowing too pushy five I really got
into big trouble yeah he's writing this
is fine yeah I need to take only focuses
this is the the real thing if I'm the
way I played I'm in bad shape really I
am I underestimated the night coming to
be five and it's always attacking you
six I cannot have no moves I'm worse in
multiple ways check check check check
yeah this was very nicely played I mean
I've know where d5 was may be more
precise even but
what Chang what I am we are here you can
take on da didn't win hmm the eye is
just quick um yeah have a look I have
absolutely nothing in this position I
can can't he gets to this and he's just
quicker this pawn is of course far too
so too far away from quitting yeah I
just said just a very bad term bad
position but this is some quite an
instructive moment after your phone I
need to take I just played this too
quickly and I was relying also on this
b5 idea getting the rook active but 94
it's really killing all my counter play
so this was very nicely done by him
thanks for watching